[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace andino en esta
edición desde Lima Perú hoy hablaremos
sobre la inestabilidad política que ha
vivido el país desde finales de 2022
luego que el expresidente Pedro Castillo
anunciara la disolución del Congreso
hecho que impulsó su destitución y su
encarcelamiento tras la caída de
Castillo Dina boluarte se convirtió en
la primera mujer en asumir la
presidencia del Perú su llegada al poder
fue rechazada con violentas protestas
que dejaron varios muertos la crisis
obligó a boluarte a recortar su mandato
Y adelantar las elecciones Para abril de
2024 los expertos afirman que los
disturbios que vive el Perú tienen más
un tinte político que social y que
existen factores externos que estarían
atacando la estabilidad de esta nación
andina
el 7 de diciembre de 2022 los peruanos
se alistaban a ver el tercer proceso de
impeachment contra Pedro Castillo lo
curioso de esta historia es que el
congreso no contaba con los 87 votos
necesarios para destituirlo y aún así
Castillo sorprendió con un mensaje al
país
disolver temporalmente El Congreso de la
República e instaurar Un gobierno de
emergencia excepcional
convocar en el más breve plazo a
elecciones para un nuevo congreso con
facultades constituyentes para elaborar
una nueva constitución en un plazo no
mayor de nueve meses tras el mensaje del
Congreso destituyó a Pedro Castillo
luego fue detenido y una corte o Renault
18 meses de prisión preventiva en su
contra por los delitos de rebelión
conspiración y abuso de autoridad o sea
tiene dos dos este dos faltas muy serias
una contra la Constitución el
ordenamiento constitucional y la otra
contra la honestidad la honradez y el
buen gobierno que son fallas muy serias
esto de terminar los juicios No bajan de
15 años de prisión efectiva Pedro
Castillo se encuentra en el penal
barbadío su prisión preventiva durará
más tiempo que el que estuvo en la
presidencia pero su encarcelamiento
podría ser más largo y tenemos nosotros
organización criminal quince años
tenemos colusión agravada 15 años
tenemos corrupción ocho años
que se suma todo esto supéralo los más
de 50 años pero el código penal señala
de que en tratados de peras temporales
solamente se le puede aplicar hasta un
máximo de 35 años quienes todavía creen
en Pedro Castillo cuestionan su decisión
de disolver El Congreso sin embargo
afirman que fue injustamente retirado
del cargo y puesto en prisión evaluando
las condiciones en realidad ni siquiera
el objetivo ha podido ser tal vez
materializar ello
si no
veamos los resultados gracias a esa
lectura Hoy está Privada de su libertad
el profesor Pedro castillo y también ha
perdido su condición de presidente de la
república entonces
en las investigaciones en el camino se
determinarán Quiénes han sido los
responsables
que han ayudado a tomar esta este tipo
de decisiones Mientras tanto la defensa
del ex mandatario alista estrategia que
permita Castillo afrontar el proceso
fuera de la cárcel
la primera tarea es liberarle de la
prisión preventiva
Es decir para que él pueda ser
investigado en libertad Esa es la tarea
fundamental ahora bien este
como abogado nosotros este
nos vamos a enfocar
atacar solamente por el tema
constitucional
si se ha vulnerado las garantías
constitucionales del debido proceso del
expresidente Pedro Castillo Y fue así
como Dina boluarte una abogada de 60
años se convirtió en la primera
presidenta en la historia del Perú el
cambio de Mando fue rechazado en
diversos puntos en Perú con protestas
que exigen la renuncia de boluarte
nuevas elecciones y el cierre del
Congreso y a mis hermanas y hermanos les
digo que con mi renuncia no se resuelve
absolutamente en este año y meses de
gobierno de transición trabajaremos las
reformas políticas
debido a la violencia la presidenta
boluarte declaró el estado de emergencia
se produjo decenas de muertes los
expertos afirman que fallaron los
servicios de inteligencia Y la
estrategia para afrontarlos y surfios
tienes todo una mezcla de gremios y de
participantes que tienen toda una
orientación política y es una protesta
política y por lo tanto la respuesta
tiene que ser más allá de un estado de
emergencia una respuesta política y para
eso el estado necesita actores políticos
además los analistas afirman que existen
intereses oscuros para desestabilizar al
gobierno y al país se cuestiona López
Obrador por estar financiado por el
narcotráfico en México que el cartel de
Sinaloa Le financió la campaña y por
otro lado tanto Evo Morales como
Castillo en Perú están vinculados a los
agricultores cocaleros el 96% de la
producción de hoja de Coca va para el
narcotráfico Y entonces ahí podría haber
una conexión
narcopolítica de Obrador con morales y
Castillo hay factores externos entonces
hoy la incógnita es sirena boluarte
completará su mandato por lo menos hasta
el 2024 Gracias por acompañarnos en esta
edición de enlace andino desde Lima Perú
sigan disfrutando de la programación de
Franz 24 en español y hasta pronto